si je vous dis smegma vous me dites et
elles ont perdu c'est pas un médicament
contre la diarrhée mais c'est pas
beaucoup plus appétissant le smegma
c'est cette substance blanchâtre pâteuse
et souvent malodorante qu'on retrouve
volontiers dans les plis de nos parties
génitales et qu'on appelle communément
du fromage de
et pourtant les femmes produisent aussi
du smegma comme les hommes grâce à des
petites glandes prévues à cet effet et
oui ce que le smegma c'est pas juste là
pour vous mettre mal à l'aise pendant un
premier date ça sert à quelque chose
c'est un composant de la fonction auto
nettoyante de notre petit matériel
intime d'ailleurs en latin et en grec
megma ça veut dire savon détergent
nettoyage c'est un mélange de la fameuse
substance sécrétée par nos petites
glandes et de cellules mortes il joue
aussi un rôle de lubrification et même
si on n'a pas encore tout bien compris
il pourrait participer à l'équilibre de
la flore génitale ça pourrait même être
une sorte de signature odorante
personnelle
smegma numéro 5 de chez michiello pas de
panique il suffit de nettoyer ça au
savon doux et à l'eau une fois par jour
et tout se passe bien